[Music]
on this Friday night 35 million people
now under lockdown China is
unprecedented quarantine as it tries to
contain the corona virus this virus has
spread through coughing and sneezing is
it contagious before symptoms emerge and
is there a test to detect it I'll speak
with an infectious disease specialist as
Europe records its first cases who wants
to replace Andrew Shearer why the
conservative leadership race has more
people out than in
a land of milk and water the candy
drawer just a taste of the impeachment
trials porkier side and getting his shot
one Toronto Raptors remarkable rise to
the top
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us a
lockdown in China is expanding tonight
as that country the epicenter of the
outbreak of a potentially deadly virus
tries to limit its spread around the
world the situation is evolving fast but
here are the numbers we know right now
roughly thirty five million people in 12
cities in China are under travel bans
tonight Chinese officials now say there
are more than 1000 confirmed cases of
the new corona virus in that country and
at least 41 people have died and more
than 8,000 are reported to be under
observation and look at this hundreds of
construction crews are working around
the clock to build a new hospital in
Wuhan where the virus was first detected
and it will be just for patients who are
ill with the virus the first cases are
now confirmed in Europe officials in
France say three people are ill they had
traveled to China that means there are
now confirmed cases in nine countries
though the vast majority are still in
China in the u.s. there is now a second
confirmed case a woman in Chicago who
returned from Wuhan on January 13th
officials say she did not show symptoms
on the flight but became ill days later
it's still not clear when people become
contagious and China is taking more
drastic steps tonight canceling all
major public events even closing the
Forbidden City in Beijing Redman Shannon
has our top story
a Lunar New Year like no other the
streets of Wuhan almost deserted a city
with a population close to that of
Ontario where no one is allowed to leave
most residents are doing as advised
staying indoors or they are stretching
the resources of Wu Hans hospitals this
footage appears to show bodies lying
next to patients being treated that is
why Chinese authorities are keen to show
off this remarkable construction project
they're building a thousand bed hospital
in one week across the region the
response is ramping up across the
country public events have been canceled
and there is a huge demand for surgical
masks and across Asia governments are
rolling out
screening measures all because just how
this new strain of the virus spreads
remains uncertain we encourage the
authorities in China to investigate a
lot into this virus and to share
whatever they find we need to know
whether we hadn't maybe develop a
vaccine against it whatever is important
thousands left the region before the
lockdown the question is were many of
those people unknowingly infectious the
key thing that determines whether case
isolation quarantine will work is
whether or not any transmission occurs
before the virus becomes symptomatic so
if that happens then of course it's very
difficult contained the death rate for
now among confirmed cases is about three
percent and many of those people had
underlying health conditions a lot less
dangerous than the recent coronavirus
MERS and probably less dangerous if you
get it than the SARS virus what we don't
know is how far it's going to spread and
that really is something we need to plan
for all eventualities the World Health
Organization says all countries need to
be ready to act quickly Redman Shannon
Global News London
public health officials in Canada say
they are ready and the riskier remains
low a handful of people who were being
monitored in Quebec have now been
cleared after tests for the virus came
back negative nine other people are now
being tested in Ontario as Eric Sorenson
reports even if there is eventually a
confirmed case here there's no reason to
panic tens of thousands of people fly
between Canada and China each year
there's every reason to believe one or
more cases of the novel coronavirus will
show up here the message from health
officials is be aware but don't panic a
vast global network of monitoring
testing and information sharing is so
much quicker and more thorough today
just the bank of technology in use at
this Toronto hospital is far more
advanced compared with when SARS swept
in 17 years ago if there's any country
in the world that's as prepared as it's
going to be it's this one
in 2003 doctors at first didn't know
SARS was a corona virus and didn't have
a test for it till halfway through the
outbreak in Toronto today a yes or no
corona virus test can come back in 24
hours and at the National Laboratory in
Winnipeg a world leader in infectious
diseases like Ebola they're working to
reduce that 24 hour period we're also
now working with n ml the national
microbiology lab our laboratory on an
even quicker test because in situations
like this speed uncertainty are both
very important dr. David Williams was in
Toronto for h1n1 and SARS today
Ontario's chief medical officer of
Health says there is immediate
cooperation internationally from
province to province and hospital to
hospital it means even if a case of
corona virus appears there's no need for
alarm
it's matter where and when but that's
part of a robust surveillance system and
a team and a group that's ready to
respond to that so I am glad to say the
machinery is in place it's working light
years ahead what we faced back in 2003
the usual advice in flu season still
applies get vaccinated wash up avoid
sick people and stay home if you're sick
meantime there will be screening
questions at Canadian airports about
previous travel to Wuhan China if the
new corona virus does come and begin
spreading in Canada
then there may be updated advice to
avoid public gatherings and such but for
now we're nowhere near there yet today
it's business as usual
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto and a
little later I'll speak with that
specialist and infectious disease about
the things we know and don't know about
this virus and what's the most vital
thing experts need to discover to
contain it now two political
developments in this country the list of
people who have said they don't want to
be leader of the federal Conservative
Party is getting longer than lists who
have said they are in the air poly EV is
the latest to bow out he says he did it
because he has a one-year-old daughter
and today he explains some advice he got
from a friend he said you should write
two letters to your daughter one telling
her why you did it and when telling her
why you didn't
and I think the letter that I read I
wrote for her that indicated my decision
not to run better one volley EV is one
of three high profile possible
contenders who in the last week have
said no thanks
so why aren't more candidates clamoring
for the top job that's what our chief
political correspondent David akin is
looking at tonight
Jean sherry on Tuesday Ronna Ambrose on
Wednesday and Pierre Paul you have on
Thursday three high profile
conservatives who one after the other
said they would not seek the federal
conservative leadership but on Saturday
another high-profile conservative will
make it official that he's in this is an
exciting journey that we're on together
and I want you to know that we need to
build a party that is going to reflect
the face of Canada Peter MacKay the
co-founder with Stephen Harper of the
modern Conservative Party of Canada left
politics in 2015 to raise a family but
now at the age of 54 he wants to
challenge for the top job in his party
and eventually take aim at the Prime
Minister's job
McKay's pitch will be that he can help
conservatives win where they've
struggled like in Ontario and Quebec
he's able to to grab some supports in
Quebec I'm pretty sure of that is
progressive fun McKay also has
endorsements from MPs and some of the
most conservative ridings in Alberta and
from MPs who are social conservatives
McKay will have challengers Ontario MP
Maryland glad you is one of them well
Peters certainly an excellent candidate
but I really think if we're talking
about growing the base we need a fresh
face and a fresh perspective instead of
the same old same old there may be
others who want to go up against Mackay
Ontario's Erin O'Toole for example but
whoever it is will have to have some
serious fundraising chops the deadline
to get in is February 20th and by then
you'd have to have a path to raise
$300,000 to get into the most expensive
leadership race in Canadian history
Donna okay David akin in Ottawa Thanks
the police in Hamilton Ontario are
searching for at least two suspects
after a child was hit by a bullet while
inside his own home
police say the seven-year-old boy was
struck when multiple gunshots were fired
into the house last night he is in
stable condition in the hospital police
believe the home was targeted but the
boy was an unintended victim he was
laying on the floor bleeding a fact his
abdomen wound wraps his hand and he just
got that's maybe who's been done three
adults and one other child were in the
home at the time but weren't hurt police
say some of the individuals are known to
them investigators believe the gunman
fled in a light colored four door sedan
Quebec provincial police have found the
body of one of those five missing
snowmobilers from France the body was
pulled from the water of the grande
charged river about two kilometers from
where the group's snowmobiles plunged
through the ice the victim's identity
has not been made public
five men disappeared on Tuesday and
their guide a 42 year old Montreal man
was pulled from the water he died later
in the hospital it's not known why the
group left the safety of the mark trail
and ventured towards an icy area that
was known to be dangerous the police in
London England are putting new cameras
into operation on the streets they call
them a new crime-fighting tool but
privacy advocates are furious the
Metropolitan Police are deploying facial
recognition cameras they say the cameras
will be clearly signposted and will be
used in small targeted areas to quickly
identify suspects wanted for serious and
violent crimes there are already
millions of police security cameras in
Britain but use of facial recognition
takes surveillance to the next level
critics say they're a serious threat to
civil liberties the first week of
President Donald Trump's impeachment
trial is wrapping up with Democrats
accusing him of a cover-up but there's
something else that has a lot of people
scratching their heads coming up what's
with all the milk drinking and the
drawer filled with sweet treats Plus
invasion of the locust the threat they
pose to the world's most vulnerable
countries
there remain a lot of unknowns about the
potentially deadly coronavirus since
word of it first began to emerge from
China on New Year's Eve dr. Michael
garden is going to help explain what we
know and don't know he's chief of staff
at Humber River Hospital and he's a
specialist in infectious disease dr.
garden China which is the epicenter of
this virus has shared the genetic
sequence of it why is that important
it's really important for a couple of
reasons one that's what the molecular
testing is based on so if you have the
sequence then you can develop a rapid
test to be able to diagnose people with
it and the other reason is ready to do
more basic science looking at how
similar is this to SARS and MERS and
other corona viruses and also the tease
out if there if there's any genes that
relate to specific virulence factors so
things that make you sicker because that
that organism has that particular gene
so all that work will be going on in the
next several months what's the most
vital thing that scientists and
specialists need to know about the virus
in order to try to control its spread
first of all the most important thing
was to have a diagnostic test which we
now have so that's that's very good but
I think right now the most important
thing is exactly how how contagious is
this if this virus becomes as contagious
as influenza for example then all the
control measures we're taking aren't
really going to slow it down if it
remains the way it is which doesn't seem
to be terribly contagious then I
actually think we have a pretty good
chance of actually stopping this
outbreak over the over the coming month
or so well let's talk about how
contagious we think it is now do we know
how long it takes for symptoms to
develop we don't have a good answer for
that yet but the the sort of the outer
limit is believed to be two weeks and so
that's what we're saying if somebody's
traveled to Wuhan City in the last two
weeks we would look at them for likely
many people it's going to be shorter
than that but it's likely not going to
be longer than that and do we know that
whether they are contagious possibly
before symptoms begin to appear you know
we we really don't know any of that yet
I'll say for other viruses we know that
people typically start shedding the
virus typically several hours
maybe a day prior to the onset of their
symptoms but the amount of virus is
usually pretty low once they start to
develop symptoms typically the amount of
virus increases many fold and they also
have symptoms at that time so typically
we think of people being the most
infectious when they actually have
symptoms and is there a definitive test
right now that can be done to determine
whether they have it or not there is a
definitive test and that's really one of
the remarkable things about this before
this virus has even landed in Canada we
already have a test for it and if you
think back to 2003 we went through most
of the SARS outbreak without a test and
so this is one of the reasons why we're
miles ahead today than we were back then
okay well I learned a lot from you dr.
Michael Gard I'm a specialist in
infectious disease thanks you're very
welcome
still ahead bullseye the perfect shot at
a little-known championship
this unprecedented invasion of locusts
is spreading across East Africa and it's
threatening food security in some of the
world's most vulnerable countries the
desert locust is considered the most
dangerous of its species the insects fly
together by the millions devouring crops
the United Nations is calling for
international help to fight the swarms
President Donald Trump made history
today he is now the first sitting
American president to attend the annual
anti-abortion rally in Washington
I am truly proud to stand with you the
March for Life rally began in 1974 a
year after the US Supreme Court
legalized abortion in the Roe versus
Wade decision American presidents have
until now avoided it drunko says unborn
children have never had a stronger
defender in the White House back in 1999
he said he was pro-choice but he changed
his tune and 81% of evangelical voters
supported him in 2016 critics accuse him
of using the March to distract from his
impeachment trial the Senators who will
decide his fate are dealing with long
days of deliberation and have to follow
some strict and surprising rules as our
Washington bureau chief Jackson prosecco
explains everything from what they can
say to what they can drink is tightly
controlled a crime against the
Constitution the serious business of
impeaching an American president this is
corruption and abuse of power in its
purest form is guided by rules both old
and a little unusual there you for
starters no talking all persons are
commanded to keep silent on pain of
imprisonment all 100 senators have to
sit there and listen no phones or
electronics allowed which has led to
reports of politicians doing crossword
puzzles or just walking away at times
are your colleagues taking these
proceedings seriously oh gosh very much
so but really when you when you've heard
it four or five times that you know it's
okay to take a bathroom break in this
miss it the fifth time on those long
impeachment days senators are only
allowed to drink water or milk in a
tradition that dates back to the 1960s
they chugged away during Bill Clinton's
impeachment
still doing it today I've seen at least
one of my colleagues drinking milk
I believe it's milk the Senate also
controls what's seen on TV there are no
independent cameras allowed
I think it's shameful that we turned off
the camera you know in the Senate we
should be able to see what people are
doing sketch artists have stepped in to
capture what you can't see the moment a
protestor burst in aboard senator
playing with a fidget spinner the
president has not complied at least no
one will get hangry while deciding the
president's fate
inside the chamber there's a single desk
full of candy for senators to dip into
what's the status of the candy drawer
the candy drawer is running a bit short
if any of you have contributions the
sweets are donated by a candy company
perhaps an a' gesture meant to soothe a
bit of the bitterness in a senate
divided over impeachment Jackson cross
Co Global News Washington
shoot for the stars next how this
Raptors shot to fame in a super short
time frame it gaps about six inches
between the two bolts oh that is just
rude the crowd laughed at the plan but
even if you don't know anything about
the sport of indoor bowls you will love
this the aim is to get your ball as
close to the yellow jack as you can an
Englishman Nick Brett did it brilliantly
well he's very close to splitting the
two red balls and getting to the jar
the target is ridiculous that is just
safety that is ridiculous
the laughter returned to applause and
his team went on to win the game of the
world indoor Bulls championships
probably one of the sports highlights of
the year well anything is possible if
you work at it
Toronto Raptors star Pascal siakam is an
example of that
the man nicknamed spicy pea has a
remarkable backstory he's gone from an
NBA nobody to an NBA all-star in the
space of four years it is he says an
honor and a dream come true
and his micro lab reports it's only the
beginning let's just put it out there
Pascal siakam wasn't supposed to be here
yet there he was learning he'd be
starting in the NBA all-star game yeah
it really is think about this he first
picked up a basketball eight years ago
in Cameroon he was to put it nicely a
raw talent but he made enough of an
impression at the giant of Africa
basketball camp created by raptors
president Masai Ujiri
that New Mexico State College took a
flyer on him there was just nothing
exceptional about Pascal siakam probably
in college and I'd say in his first
couple years as a pro there was promised
that he could be a good player but
nothing to the point that we're seeing
still Yuji Ruiz Raptors drafted him
which was a mystery to critics who said
they could have done so much better
Ujiri just laughed this kid is fresh and
he's still laughing because in four
short years siakam won the Most Improved
Player Award
honoring his father who died shortly
before Pascal's first game in college he
had this crazy dream you know and people
back home never believed in him and and
he always believed you know this would
be possible one day and now the skinny
kid from Cameroon has a 100 million
dollar contract to go along with the
championship he helped the team win last
year and while the Raptors former star
Kawhi Leonard hated any and all
attention siakam couldn't be more
different
it was of course a joke because you'd be
crazy to return the Jersey that belongs
to one of the unlikeliest stars
basketball has ever seen
electrolyte global news Toronto and that
is global national for this Friday I'm
donor freezing tonight sir Canada is
Grand Prix Nova Scotia we'd love to see
your Canada please email it to us and
thanks for watching
Robin Gill will be here at the anchor
desk over the weekend and I will see you
back here on Monday have a lovely
weekend bye bye
[Music]